è come un fratello per me quale si
suggerivano prima che quando ti dicono
se come un fratello di dire che ami
l'incesto ciao ragazzi benvenuti alla
nuova rubrica qui sul mio canale che ho
deciso di chiamare vita buttata perché
perché a novembre farò 30 anni mi sono
reso conto che quello che ho fatto col
mio tempo è stato il più delle volte
sprecarlo
personalmente la firenze ma accompagnato
più o meno da
i due anni quando pensavo che mia mamma
volesse più bene a me invece la più
bella mio fratello è accompagnato anche
le medie
quando mi ero innamorato di luisa e
secondo me se mi si è quello di cos'è
per questa cosa mi dirà prima o poi lui
sarà una bellissima ragazzina dai
capelli rossi che poi si fidanzò con mio
cugino al liceo invece i ruoli si sono
invertiti offrendo nato io una mia
carissima amica ma perché no tanto
confuso al liceo quindi insomma mi
dispiace comunque questa nemica si
sposerà a breve quindi che alla fine ho
vinto lei la cosa che ho chiesto ad
alcuni di voi naturalmente visto che
questo vorrei che fosse un dialogo in
qualche modo con ragazzine coetaneo
comunque parlano la mia lingua è stato
di mandarmi dei messaggi vocali su
facebook
l'ho chiesto ovunque e sono
contentissimo perché mi sono arrivati un
boato è una cosa sulla quale voglio
rassicurare i morbosi ma soprattutto le
persone che mi hanno scritto e che non
utilizzerò assolutamente i vostri nomi
reali tom cruise mi manda un messaggio
che è il seguente sono che senza filippo
[Musica]
va ben maggiore lo dicono nido v12
aldrin sito in cui ho sperato invano che
il mio miglior amico si rendesse conto
che cercava di farlo mollare con tutte
le tv con le quali si metteva e sto
cercando di baciarlo mentre avevo
casualmente inserito friendly bene che
c'è nel lettore dvd non era perché ero
preclude dolcissimo ma in lista d'attesa
per donargli in utero e lui non ha mai
capito un cazzo
no non so di che cosa tu stia parlando
i piedi
il mio rapporto con la sentono può
essere definito dello struzzo
partendo dal fatto che io pur di parlare
con lui ho imparato tutto il codice
morse e poi lui tranquillamente ha
deciso di scaricarmi dicendomi che mi
facevo il boy scout sapeva scrivere in
codice morse mi diceva che per parlare
con lui devo assolutamente impararla non
diamogli in codice morse [ __ ]
spero che lasciare il posto a fo che
troverà una bella persona quello che
effettivamente no perché sono troppo
grassa per i suoi standard e quindi non
potevo essere adatta magari se fosse
dimagrita
forse ci sarebbe voluto provare a fare
qualcosa ma io credo che non è solo la
risposta dove l'unica azione da
intraprendere sia quella cioè se vuoi di
prezzo una carabina cioè trovare un modo
[Musica]
si pensava che io
per la maggior parte della mia vita e ho
24 anni sono stati senza nata da gente
omosessuale vorrei fare un appello a
tutti quanti gli omosessuali che stanno
là fuori
questa è una cosa che non si fa perché
un sacco di persone mi stanno vista 200
questa cosa è la realtà secondo me è che
voi pensate che sia palese e magari per
la ragazza che mi sta di fianco non è
palese quindi voi magari la vedete come
la relazione più pulita del mondo e il
loro nel frattempo tornano a casa è
capito si mangiano il gelato e si
accerto tutto sei tipo o piange davanti
un film ti piace il capo è quello è più
o meno il tuo approccio
vabbè delicato dopo che mi sono
dichiarato nick davvero tu mi piaci
tanto tantissimo
no non possiamo stare insieme scusa non
ce la faccia è il 46 tipo volta io
allora io voglio improntare questa
rubrica sulla base dell'onestà ok se non
vuoi sentire quello che ho da dire
esci betti in pausa fai quello che ti
pare
matt ha detto una gran cazzata da detto
una cazzata cosmica
innanzitutto dico a questo ragazzo
fargli vedere questo video non so
cresce un paio di palle si noto non puoi
tenere appeso una persona con una
cazzata del genere magari una persona
pure buona dolce che pensi in qualche
modo di ferire di meno dicendo una cosa
di questo tipo dire semplicemente che
non ti piace tu puoi uscire per questo
momento esatto non è un attimo in bagno
la sfuriata spiccare fuoco alla macchina
se vi piace qualcuno non toccate l'alcol
quando siede vicino a lui ma veramente
ve lo dico col cuore perché c'è un
momento che l'alcol ti regala nel quale
ti senti invincibile non lo sai che devo
fare qualcosa e giura che non sono fatta
e come gioca il gene in cui mi è
capitato di schiaffeggiare qualcuno
ho sentito di un dj quindi di base
doveva essere mezzo
diamo che cazzo dici
ciao che ripensano il periodo freddo
viene voglia di vedermi a grandate
pretesa che poi è meglio via potrebbe
pure essere un modo alternativo per
lavarsi i denti e manu chao vogliamo o
vista che chiesto di parlare le nostre
esperienze con la rendono praticamente
una volta una ragazza mi ha definito il
ragazzo che tutte le ragazze meritano ma
non quello di cui ha bisogno
in poche parole che sono il cavaliere
oscuro della franzoni batman di nolan di
questa città piena di anime inter se ci
pensi essere frenati è come essere
poveri e del praja disney store
potresti prendere quel pupazzo di stizza
tutti i costi però la signorina non può
darcelo perché dice che non è abbastanza
soldi per comprarlo
ad ogni modo dire la prendono siano
stati molto vicini non perché mi fa
avevamo un rapporto molto intimo seppur
a senso unico
mi stava cantano menichini non vi
lascerà mai da solo e mi assistiamo ogni
volta che avrei voluto spararne un
solitario sulla pisciotta che non
contraccambiava il desiderio della
popolazione ventimila posso dire che a
quel tempo avrebbe ragionato con piacere
la stessa solo che sono testardo quindi
sarà entrato lo stesso di nestorio con
più soldi e infezioni di spicchio
personale certo non fosse li buttava lo
uccide come il baccalà del mercato
sicuro mattutino quindi diciamo alle
volte la prendo non è un pericolo non
suggerimento del mondo della natura e di
madre natura
bravo questo è un bel modo di vederla
anche perché secondo me è un modo per
schermare perché va bene sembra tipo
cose così però effettivamente se una
cosa è fatta per te
celestino un po ragazzi sono arrivati
alla fine di questo esperimento che
avevano così spero veramente che vi sia
piaciuto voi scrivetemi qua sotto a
parte quella che è stata la vostra
esperienza con la franzoni soprattutto
in questo momento sto cercando consigli
quindi se avete capito lo spirito di
questa rubrica ecco datemi una mano
magari mettetevi dei like per insomma a
farmi capire anche quelle potrebbe
essere l'argomento che più vi piace io
ringrazio la botta jazz simone cioè che
sono stati qui con me a da farmi
compagnia volte li avete sentiti e
niente vi saluto alla prossima